[Music]
2024 is on the move and it's already
shaping up to be a very big year for TV
among the new shows coming your way are
some recognizable titles via various
adaptations along with the biggest of
the big franchises dropping their latest
and some brand new Original Stories
ready to be told too it's all on an
extra- large episode of this week's what
to watch you are in charge of 35 planes
and 350 air crew
man don't you die on me before I get
over there landing on Apple TV Plus in
January is the drama miniseries masters
of the air this show is considered a
companion to the certified fresh
miniseries Band of Brothers from 2001
and the Pacific from 2010 and much like
those projects this one was executive
produced by Steven Spielberg and Tom
Hanks masters of the air takes place
during World War II and is based on the
popular 2007 book by Donald L Miller
about members of the Air Force's 100th
Bomb Group who fought the air war
against the Nazis they didn't bring up
that we'd be pairing to the last
interview it's an old kgp tactic draw us
attention as a
[Music]
couple coming in early February to
Netflix is the Spy comedy Mr and Mrs
Smith no it's not the 2005 movie with
brangelina go ask your parents about
that nickname kids but rather a brand
new show based on that movie created by
Donald Glover and Franchesca Sloan who
was most recently a writer on Glover
show Atlanta he also stars in this one
as the mister with Maya kkin as the
misss two strangers who end up working
for a mysterious spy agency while posing
as a married C and they're not alone in
this story with a strong Supporting Cast
that includes Paul do Sarah pson and
Alexander Skarsgard to name a
[Music]
few to help warm you up in late February
will be the liveaction series version of
avatar The Last Airbender this is an
adaptation of the popular animated
series of the same name that ran for
three 100% fresh seasons on Nickelodeon
so a lot to live up to or a great
Foundation already set the depends on
how you look at it the promising young
cast is led by Gordon Cormier as Ang a
12-year-old Airbender who was frozen in
ice for 100 years and emerges to find a
war torn world that he needs to save
Cormier is coming off a big role in the
2020 miniseries the stand and will now
be standing front and center as the face
of this Netflix series do not be fooled
by our
politeness our bows our ma of
rituals death is an our air also
arriving in late February will be the
historical drama series shun this Hulu
FX show is based on the popular 1975
novel of the same name by James claval
which was previously adapted into a
miniseries in 1980 and if you think that
sounds like a long time ago well the
story is set in the year 1600 and
follows Lord Yoshi toranaga played by
Hero Yuki Sonata as he tries to defeat
his enemies this series was created by
husband and wife team Justin Marx and
Rachel condo Justin was one of the
writers for top gun Maverick and also
created the Stars Espionage Thriller
counter part lovely to me you madam
Chancellor good love this king fisher
blue or try not to get blood on it
hitting HBO in March is a miniseries
called the regime this show looks at a
year inside of fictional central
European autocracy as the regime that's
running it begins to unravel the show
features an Allstar cast led by Kate
Winslet as the chancellor of the
autocracy Martha Plimpton as the US
Secretary of State and Hugh Grant as the
leader of the opposition whose
imprisonment is a central storyline for
the series there must be 30 dead
scientists in the past
month Christ another countdown hitting
Netflix on March 21st is the Sci-Fi
series called three body problem this
show was created by David benof and DB
Weiss who brought us Game of Thrones and
Alexander Ru who was a writer on True
Blood and the cast also features some
recognizable go faces like John Bradley
Liam Cunningham and Jonathan price three
by body problem is based on the 2008
novel of the same name by leua Shin it
centers around a decision made by an
astrophysicist in 1960s China that
reverberates across space and time into
the present day becoming the greatest
threat in Humanity's history which is I
we got to wait till March you need to go
home Vault dwellers are an endangered
species I do not think you would be
willing to do what it takes to survive
up here April will be bringing the
post-apocalyptic drama series Fallout
this show is of course based on the
widely popular and long running
roleplaying video game franchise that
has been around since 1997 and its
Westworld creators Jonathan Nolan and
Lisa Joy who are taking it from the game
console to Prime video the series stars
Ella Pernell of yellow jackets Fame as
Lucy the main protagonist meanwhile
Walton Goggins who is great in
everything he does plays the ghoul a
mutated Bounty Hunter who has seen some
things or aka the guy from the trailer
who is missing a nose slated for late
2024 is the new Marvel series Agatha
darkhold Diaries this MCU show is
actually a spin-off from 2021s W
division with fan favorite kathern Han
reprising her role as Agatha Harkness a
witch who showed up on that series to
try and steal Wanda maximoff's Powers
spoiler alert I guess darkhold Diaries
takes place after the events of w
division with Agatha on a quest to get
her old powers back and she brings along
an unlikely crew of witches to help her
played by folks like Aubrey Plaza and
Patty LuPone the world a buil for guys
like
us that's why we got to take whatever we
decide is ours emerging on Max in late
2024 is the DC series The Penguin this
is a spin-off from the certified fresh
film The Batman from 2022 picking up one
week after the film's events and looking
at the Penguin's rise to power in Gotham
City's bad guy underworld reprising his
role from the movie is Colin Ferell as
the penguin who will be going toe to
Finn with Sophia Falcone played by
Kristen motti a daughter of Crime Boss
Carmine Falcone who is looking to take
criminal control after her father's
death and while we're talking about
staple franchises with new series we got
to mention the seventh liveaction Disney
plus Star Wars show the acolyte this one
takes place at the end of the high
Republic era about a 100 years before
the events of The Phantom Menace when a
former Padawan teams back up with her
Jedi Master to investigate a string of
crimes the acolyte was created by Leslie
Hedland who co-created Netflix's Russian
doll and stars Amanda Stenberg as the
former Padawan and Le Jung Jay as her
Jedi Master keran Moss also plays a Jedi
in this one because that's just what
badasses do there you go 10 new titles
to get you all revved up about the year
2024 in TV be sure to let us and your
fellow viewers know in the comments what
your most excited for whether it was on
this list or not remember to check out
roto.com for the latest updates on
scores and reviews for everything
mentioned as well as the movie and TV
World At Large that's all for today
fresh family until next week stay
fresh